[Music]  the high school is the foundation for  the rest of your life there's only one  chance and first impression that work  hard put your heart out there and don't  go into high school without backup  you need to stick together to survive  die  well last thing don't bomb on say high  school is an app for reinvention but I  say that  goodbye romance hello drama [ __ ] be  bonkers  [Music]  loyalty Trump's victory kanpai  I see you and I'm down with it  I like the freaky  [Music]  baby  [Music]  what happened with sticking together you  don't understand all this life it's my  destiny it's to it  how are we gonna survive high school  [Music]  you please break down what's going on  it's complicated  we're dysfunctional understatement we  don't even look it's Brentwood nothing  bad happens you how about OJ no offense  Jamal go I'm good  we don't claim him  you